I just think that it's
I just think it's absolute nonsense to
be honest that to imagine that women the
LGBT people that Minority people aren't
already some of the most robust people
out there because to survive
which is what we're talking about in
when when we're using this like you know
psychological framework to survive to
thrive to flourish in this deeply uh
deeply oppressive Society in many ways
you need to be robust I would love it if
what we were talking about when we were
talking about safety culture is a set of
tactics where I didn't need to think
about sexism I didn't need to worry
about anti-Semitism for another day
brilliant I can just take these tools
and put myself in a little bubble and
you know so what if I get paid less at
work and so what if I you know get
assaulted on the night bus home I'm so
that's not what we're talking about here
what we're talking about here
is
creating the spaces necessary for people
who are already robust
to encounter the things to confront head
on the structures that day to day we
don't have the mental time
to address now for me that's not about
shutting down debate those are precisely
the conditions it takes to confront
honestly and with intellectual rigor the
kind of structures on which our society
is founded now in the book we talk about
uh being triggered in the right
circumstances as
um in CBT as a uh
as a necessary process for growth I
completely agree
um I've actually I've had a PTSD
diagnosis myself I've been through CBT
it's cognitive behavioral therapy
behavioral therapy by the book
um but um
um
you talk about PTSD thank you um
but that's precisely what safe spaces
are they are structures where people can
people can people can allow themselves
to confront material and to bring New
Perspectives in to institutions that
usually exclude them now as an academic
I want to embrace that I want to embrace
what is a flourishing a proliferation of
viewpoints and of course the ways in
which those viewpoints are brought in
and addressed are not going to look the
same as the ways in which we were used
to in the past because the people and
the perspectives are changing right
that's one of the gifts of feminist
epistemology right that there are all
kinds of ways of inquiry in all kinds of
ways of knowing things and we should be
embracing that that's not
anti-intellectual let me just ask you
that in terms of embracing
um views you don't like would you say
you would not want to hear a sexist
voice on campus you would not want to
hear a
right-wing voice on campus or an extreme
right-wing voice on campus have you been
to UCL I'm off for you I'm just this
this is this is to help us out in terms
of because the the problem is that you
are deciding where those lines are set
what is unpalatable to you I mean
I think that's
uh no no like I'm not saying you are
mischaracterizing saying that this is a
mischaracterization right sorry it's
very convenient mischaracterization if
you want to paint this like tiny
minority of the left as the real enemies
of society and distract from everything
else that's going on but okay cool
um what's Happening Here is to say that
like
when uh what safety what safe space is
is to say that what we need to do when
we're in this room is to be mindful of
how our language and how our behaviors
affect other people and this is a space
in which we can confront the structures
that we move through every day in a
considered
um compassionate way and what a trigger
warning is is not I'm not going to read
this book but I need to take a breath
take a little pause
in order that I can read this book
and the hysteria around having a
30-second pause or needing to step out
the room for a bit is to me the real you
know that's the real hysteria here okay
so if if it is just about
um the use of language the use of
kindness of compassion there is nothing
for chief Rabbi to disagree with there
is there
well you know I'm always willing to
disagree
that's you get to be Chief
but I mean you know I just I just want a
friend to step back and put it in a
slightly larger frame one thing has
bothered me for the last 50 years we
have focused on two institutions one
favored by the left one favored by the
right namely
the state and the market
state is about the creation and
distribution of power Market about the
creation and distribution of wealth
and the right tends to find market-based
Solutions the left tends to find
state-based Solutions I don't let
anything hang on that
but it seems to me that we have always
historically had healthy societies when
we had a third Arena
because the state and the market are
both about competition
they're about
what in the short term a zero-sum games
the more power
I give away the less I have the more
money I give away the less I have
there has to be a third Arena which
we sometimes call Civil Society of a Key
Arena of which is the University which
is not about competition it's about
collaboration and cooperation and we
need to learn how to cooperate as well
as how to complete compete
what I object to and what is very
dangerous
is if you turn the university into a
version of the market I.E you get
privilege according to how you can pay
or you turn it into a version of this
state where what's really at stake is
relationships of power and Candy you've
said that universities are to be
understood as relationships of power and
that to me is is an allegation that
needs to be taken terribly seriously are
people using power to impose their views
on others or silence views they don't
want to hear universities have to stand
aside as a third sector we will learn to
trust one another listen to one another
respect one another's differences and I
think we're losing that and we can ask
you a lot of questions bear with me let
me take your imagination for a walk if
you replace the word university with
gentlemen's club right which is what it
may sound like if you come from a
minority that does not expect you in it
does that change if instead of saying
University you say in this gentleman's
club we have to you you know push back
against the rule that doesn't allow
women we have to push back against the
law that makes black men feel
uncomfortable does it then change look
it's as the son of a guy who sells what
is in commercial Road I.E you know
Lowery's side sort of stuff uh that's
exactly what university looked like to
me I've wandered into this Gentleman's
Club where clearly I don't belong
and it was a scary experience I have to
say this and then I suddenly discovered
that all these very very well often
aristocratic and public school guys are
willing to sit down and argue and when
we're talking seriously from the heart
with passion but with Lucidity all of a
sudden those distinctions of class and
and and and and privilege just
disappeared
and for a moment that that was for me an
epiphany that said to me this isn't a
gentleman's club here is a place where I
as a Jew a cognitive minority
representing less than one half of one
percent of the population of this
country I have a voice here I have a
place here and the same must apply to
blacks it must apply to LGBT it must
apply to any minority they have to feel
this is not a club that excludes me and
therefore I won't exclude the other
voices in his Club yeah but the
um but the truth is that's not what
happens and the idea that the university
is a third space that's not true the
university has always been an expression
of state power and Market power right so
the university justifies slavery at a
time when you need slavery for example
and going to this point about 2010 has
been a big change but what happened in
2008 there was a major financial crisis
which Unleashed Leo liberalism in a way
that had not been seen on the University
sector the university sector is just a
market like there is no barrier to that
at all and when you look at things like
fees if you look at the price of
accommodation if you look at competition
the market that is probably the better
explanation for why you're having these
problems with students than because
they're being Molly cuddled actually the
this University is the market and the
market is racism and that market
excludes people many minorities and
that's really the problem we're talking
about here and what really is being said
in safe spaces or no platforming or
trigger warnings is you have a group of
students now in this Market if you like
and they are saying we should be the
ones who decide what speech what what is
okay speech because I think we'd all
agree that not every not all speech is
okay you wouldn't have Osama Bin Laden
coming to the University campus right
but that's not just an objective
decision well maybe you would I don't
think most people would right but at
some point you're always going to have
no platform and there's always a level
where you say look Holocaust denier
don't come to the university right but
who is it that has the power to decide
whether Steve Bannon should come I would
argue if the students you should not be
the duns in the elite and if the
students get together and say we don't
want this person then that's a perfectly
fine expression of their Free Will right
and it's right to speak so
so I think we we can all agree that
universities like most institutions uh
used to be like gentlemen's clubs used
to exclude women or or people of African
descent I think we all agree that there
used to be enormous racism we can all
agree that many groups we can talk about
today as historically marginalized I
think we all agree to that and our
debate comes down to have we made no
progress a little progress or enormous
progress and if we've made enormous
progress should we continue or you might
think we've made little and therefore we
need to try a totally new way so I'd
like to share with you what happened to
me when I was on well so when I was on a
panel at uh soon after I wrote an
article in the Atlantic with Greg
Luciano in 2015 there was a panel
organized at the New York University law
school to talk about this and uh one of
the the one of the participants was a
law student of a Latin American descent
who was talking about being a Latino
student at NYU Law and she was talking
about the the constant violence
perpetrated on her and I asked her to
elaborate on that what do you mean
violence like actual like physical
violence and she said no no not physical
violence but but violence nonetheless
and she said well I mean you have to
admit that this University was not built
for it was not designed for people like
me
and I looked around the panel and I said
okay I'll agree to that wasn't built for
people like me I'm Jewish it wasn't
built for people like her she's Chinese
American it wasn't built for him he's a
gay half black
um uh British uh philosopher wasn't
built for any of us isn't that wonderful
isn't that progress
and to take the fact of historical
Prejudice as a reason to feel excluded
today as a reason to damn an institution
that is trying its hardest to overcome
that to increase diversity this is what
we're talking about with great on Truth
number two what we call the untruth of
emotional reasoning always trust your
feelings if you're catastrophizing if
you're deliberately trying to if you're
deliberately telling students this
institution is against you see
oppression everywhere people here hate
you they will do anything to stop you
that's a really good recipe to
disempower them if you want to make the
black students at NYU Law fail tell them
that
okay
so take that phrase I don't mind which
of your answers
stop seeing oppression everywhere
because that is ultimately what's
holding back minorities that's one of
the things there's others
but it might actually be appreciative I
don't know I don't know
um I think
um
it is profoundly patronizing isn't it to
say that um to respond to someone's Cry
of pain as a rabbi sex uh so so uh
eloquently put and with
your pain is not valid
uh your pain is in fact a cognitive
distortion is a misdiagnosis of the
world and I think when when to say that
um that um University students reason
purely from emotion is is just untrue
that is the great untruth here
um but what we need to talk about here
is that when um many mainstream
philosophers at the moment Center uh
emotional uh emotional factors like
intuition like uh private pain
um like distress what that is is a
corrective to a long history of people
who have experienced depression being
told
um you're misdiagnosing your situation
you're lying you're overestimating uh
what's happening to you when really all
of these are just historical tactics
that have been used to silence dissent
and to get people to shut up basically
now I'm not saying that that's what
you're doing but I am saying that that
is very convenient for people who are
trying to do that and I'm saying that
that those kinds of convenient
narratives that we are inculcating in
our universities invite invite a kind of
um very damaging framework and I'm not
talking about damaging as in like
discomforting I'm talking about damaging
to the fabric of exactly the kind of
free
um robust institution that we're all
invested in now I just want to come back
on one thing that Rabbi sack said
um is that two things
um when we are engaging in a free in a
free debate there is this kind of sense
of a contract there is a sense of give
and take that I disagree with your views
but I will respect your free speech and
you disagree with My Views but you
respect my free speech that is not the
case when you are talking about Steve
and his many compatriots that is not the
case when you are talking about the free
at far right because the far right is
invested
politically and tactically in depriving
those rights from many many people and
yes Jewish people thank God have a
wonderful history of debate and arguing
Christ like I I'd know that from like
from half of my family and it's one of
my favorite things about like going to
see my aunties but Jewish people also
have a very Noble history of drawing a
line somewhere and that line is always
always
to stop fascist mobilizing because we
know that they pose us a direct threat
that was the line that was drawn in
cable Street in 1936 that was the line
that was drawn in lewisham in 1978 and
both of those times it worked and when
we we would be so naive to not learn the
lessons of History